il y a eu des problèmes partout il y en
a encore mais enfin ils s'arrangent très
très bien et on a des contacts ils sont
pris voici là jamais été question
justement de se presser de supprimer la
profession foraine une telle
manifestation est ce qu il s'en est déjà
produit en france
euh non on peut dire que non c'est bien
une première rennes va faire école si on
peut dire dans ce sens c'est que les
forains de toute la région du pays de la
bretagne entière puisque nous avons des
collègues qui descendent d'un peu
partout pour nous épauler cas il est un
fait que sirène supprime ces forains et
bien ça serait un précédent et que notre
profession ne peut pas tolérer
au départ il est c'était un mouvement le
calme et enfin étant donné que rennes ne
donne pas satisfaction ça devient un
mouvement à l'échelon national
un problème matériel vous n'êtes ni
branché pour l'électricité ni pour l'eau
comment allez-vous remédier à cela et
bien écoutez ce serait quand même
aberrant aussi itunes ou vivant que
cinquante familles foraine ne puisse pas
avoir tout au moins à l'électricité ou
l'eau puis je pense que la direction de
l'edf ils nous sont très contents de
nous raccorder s'il trouve justement des
points de branchement en dehors de ça
vous savez comme moi qu'il y à des
groupes électrogènes silencieux et que
nous pouvons
puisque la plupart des manèges ont
également leur groupe électrogène
c'est vraiment une des seules villes en
france je pense qu'il devra pas vos
difficultés s'implanter ailleurs
premièrement deuxièmement si nous avons
pris la décision c'est année c'est tout
à fait une année en passant c'est parce
que si les décisions qui étaient prises
antérieurement sur ims ip d'intérieur
comme pour la nôtre il y avait plus de
places disponibles dans le centre de la
ville alors nous étudions un projet pour
l'avenir qui en principe devrait
franchir les prochaines
mais cette année il n'y a pas eu
possibilité de trouver un lieu
d'implantation
nous avons été émus monsieur duval et
moi même qu'ils aient recevions part
évidemment le problème humain
incontestable qui se posent précédente
de famille et mon collègue au cours de
la réunion s'est dit peut-être que nous
pourrions dégager un terrain que celle
qu'ils soient libres à l'heure actuelle
à rennes et qui évidemment n'était pas
prévu pour cela et à tel point que nul
ne lâchant pas nous sommes rendus les
forêts moi-même à l'emplacement et ils
ont estimé eux que c'était un terrain
vague qui ne pourrait pas leur convenir
alors il s'installe en centre de ville
sur le champ de mars
oui est ce que vous comptez les en
déloger alors ceci n'est pas de mon
ressort de ma délégation si on peut dire
mais il faudrait bien appliquer la loi
[Musique]